next year gigi will be completely
different the year after gigi will be
completely different but she will always
be that fashion illustration don't get
it twisted
i'm gg good and today i'm unfiltered
from my home
it usually takes around an hour to an
hour and a half to do
my drag makeup and i've been doing it
nearly every single day while i'm in
quarantine just because it's
you know it's meditation
oh my god powder everywhere
i don't think there's much of a
difference between sam and gigi
um except for the obvious visual
difference but
i almost feel like gigi is
the the most fully realized version of
sam
that there is gigi is is what sam used
to play with
as a little kid and becoming gigi is
just becoming all the barbies that
i used to dress up and braid hair for
it's just playing dress up so you can
see all this debris floating through the
camera
of the powder let me just
fan that out of the way
[Music]
gender has never been on the forefront
of my mind
it's never been something that was
important for me to address it's never
been something that i've been taught
about
or knowledgeable of i do remember
constantly being drawn to feminine
things
more than masculine things and there was
a moment which i i don't remember
because i was so young i think i was two
or three at this point but my mom
always brings it up whenever we're
talking about my
my gender experience and my journey and
it's that um
we were in the car one day on the way to
get groceries or church or something i
don't know
i asked my mom why did god make me
a boy i'm not supposed to be a boy i'm
supposed to be a girl
and from a three-year-old's point of
view
it's kind of hard to wrap your head
around where they might have
gotten any of this information from and
that's why my mom always talks about it
is because it seemed like such a genuine
innocent thing that came across my mind
that just
was something that i could casually
bring up
gender has always been something that's
it's just never been important to me
so right now i am cream contouring
now on to concealing and powdering
[Music]
i started drag at age
15 which was i guess you could say i
started drag because that's kind of when
i became aware of the actual term
but i've been you know dressing up as
a girl for as long as i can remember it
was just something that was never
needed a term it was just something that
i always did my mom has this
cedar closet in our basement that is
just like packed full
of vintage dresses and hats and
accessories and gloves and jewelry and
at this time
my dad still didn't really know about it
so it was kind of like
it was almost like a little speakeasy me
and my mom going down to the basement to
get this figured out
and picture like a movie montage of try
on and i would step out of the closet
and she'd be sitting there like
no and then i go back and you know it's
fun it was just fun it was fun to play
dress-up with my mom like we used to do
the very first thing that my mom made me
was
this white wedding dress i had a veil i
did lies by marina and the diamonds and
i threw a bouquet
into the audience and i think that might
have been the first time that my mom was
sitting in the audience as well
to see kind of her light up and
understand that
she wasn't making a dress for a drag
queen
she was making something for her son to
wear in order to bring
passion into his life and in order to
make him
feel as comfortable in his own skin as
possible which i
and she believes is the number one
rule for a parent
i don't think that i have been
concealing anything when it comes to my
relationship with crystal
i kind of think that it's been hidden in
plain sight
no one's just been willing to dig deep
enough now i'm
ready for my first show cause finally
now i don't hate the music i love
crystal with
my whole heart i thought i didn't give
it about what people thought
[Music]
but when i met crystal and understood
that
her drag is for nobody else except for
her
that is like immediately when i just
fell
head over heels for her and i just feel
like
relationships nowadays are
so much more than just a label and i
just
have never believed in that i don't
think that that's necessary
i do not ever see us losing contact from
each other or falling out of love
i am about to start my brows i've got my
base
on and set it does not quite look like
skin yet but it will
soon i don't glue my brows down i
stopped gluing my brows down when i
realized that it was just not like
i it always looked crusty every time i
did it and now i know how to do it when
i'm doing makeup on other people or when
i want a no brow look but
i've just tweezed my brows
to hell and back and so now it's just
like
this it's i live with spock eyebrows
every day now
i am gonna take some time and review
the fashions that i wore on my season of
drag race
gigi good
[Laughter]
one look i want to do over is the purple
runway which was my
daphne inspired look daphne is my
literal and i'll be all inspiration when
it comes to
female power i just did not think i did
her justice
and i i would love to redo that runway
look
my favorite look and i think maybe one
of the most quintessential
gigi looks was the pastel
runway motorcycle look which my mom
made out of tablecloths from our church
during easter time
i am so obsessed with like 80s biker
chick
one look that did not get enough love
and i will
fight until i die for this is my buttons
and bows
look she's so buttoned up which was the
look that i did that was covered in 25
000
orange buttons that were all hand placed
on every single piece me and my
really close friends um just
spent morning and night gluing buttons
to that outfit and i still find buttons
in the nooks and crannies of my
apartment to this day
honestly i wish i would have packed more
looks because by the end of it i did end
up having to actually
borrow something from some other girls
which i
never ever thought i was going to have
to do rupaul's drag race bringing
families together since 2009
[Music]
in the beginning my relationship with
my dad in in regards to drag
was really tough because it it came to a
point where when he found out that i was
doing drag
um he would need to be warned
when i was coming upstairs when i was
about to leave the house so that he
could leave the room and not have to
feel you know disgusted that
his son is wearing women's clothes
now obviously as time has gone on our
relationship has gotten a lot better
especially because of the show
and the show really opened up a
conversation that needed to be had
for so long and it was
you know i i didn't i had never heard my
dad
say that he's proud of me until after he
realized
what his attitude towards me you know
how that played in effect to my my
psyche and
my relationship with him and my family
in general
once that piece of the puzzle finally
came in
it was just like a liberation it was
just like a weight that was just like
okay finally now let's continue with
with our lives
i owe a hundred percent of my success to
my mom's acceptance of me at such a
young age because it was something that
i
never had to work for and i believed
that i
could do anything i wanted because she
told me to and a lot of kids have to
fight for that
and i'm not going to cry because then we
will have to start over with my eye
makeup
my situation in regards to beauty has
always kind of been a little bit of a
double life
in that if i'm feeling some type of way
about myself out of drag all i have to
do is
get in drag and then feel beautiful i've
been rejected
countless times by men just because of
my
body type and because you know you can
see my ribs
when my shirt is off and my elbows are
super
bony and all throughout high school and
college i had the
worst like the worst acne on my body
and you would not catch me
dead in a short sleeve shirt or a pair
of shorts
people are always critiquing why i only
have one silhouette and it's because of
those
those insecurities that i had of not
wanting to show my arms or my back
the michelle visage runway where i was
in a little bikini
was so scary to me and
the reason i chose that look was because
i was taking power back
from that one silhouette that i've
relied on because of those insecurities
it all comes back to taking those
insecurities and flipping them around
through drag fun tip for you people out
there who want to live
on the edge you just take fire
and set your eyelash curler a flame
honey oh yeah that's really hot
you just wait for it to cool down a
little bit and then it's the exact same
thing
as curling your hair with a hot curling
iron and
when i found out about this oh baby it
changed the world because it just curls
it right up to share
oh stunning
oh the lash just always changes
everything
it is a very like commonly known thing
right now
in the drag community that um
statistically drag queens of color
have far less followers than um
non-poc drag queens um
the reason for that being who knows
except for it's just rooted in racism
and i just think there are a lot of fans
that are saying they're not racist but
again it comes from
their parents beliefs and the beliefs of
the people who raised them
where that that just trickles down and
they may not outwardly do it but
they are being racist in a way that
they're like i'm not racist i'm just
not following jade essence hall it's
it's a hard conversation to have because
it's never really been talked about but
right now
is the time to talk about it
we've got the lips we're gonna move on
to some gloss
wow stunning something i wish
i wouldn't have said on camera
on drag race you're a singing performer
but they've told you week after week
that you have to improve on your face i
in untucked during the frozen
runway when i asked heidi about her
makeup
that whole process from then going on
have regretted the way that that came
out of my mouth so
hard because on tv it really made it
seem like i was just like
reading her for her makeup abilities i
just love
and respect heidi so much i wish i had
never opened my mouth and said anything
clearly the [ __ ] has learned how to do
her makeup
now that her face is flawless that [ __ ]
is invincible
well now that we've got the face on
she's on i'm actually so excited about
all this turned out to shame i'm gonna
have to just
take it off and then get back into bed
after this but i am going to change into
my wig
and my outfit and uh
i'll be right back
oh my god are you okay
i forgot i was still attached to a
microphone
[Music]
and welcome back to my face
oh my god i've got my hair on
i think i feel the most beautiful
when when i become
the barbie that i've always played with
and
i'm lucky enough that that happens every
single time i get into drag
because to me it's just it's no
different it is absolutely no different
than
you know picking out which doll you want
to play with and how you're gonna dress
her up and what career she's gonna have
that day
and um i i feel the most beautiful
when i'm gigi because gigi is sam's
inner beauty